[Musique]
bonsoir ça fait bientôt un mois
consensus nous sommes de nouveau confiné
quand en sortirons nous demain présent
république va peut-être donner un début
de réponse sur l'ouverture des magasins
par exemple il va peut-être être
question aussi des vaccins on verra ça
donc dans 24 heures maintenant
des sujets qui font débat à droite
notamment on estime que les commerces
paie le prix fort des mesures sanitaires
les républicains qui ont voté aussi
contre la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que ce soit aussi
bien à l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
et puis il ya un autre sujet de discorde
qui va bientôt arriver dans les débats
c'est sur la loi dite pour conforter les
principes républicains autant dire que
ce sont des heures de débats
parlementaires à venir
et ça tombe bien on reçoit aujourd'hui
dans l'édition publique gérard larcher
bonsoir soir les présidents du sénat et
vous êtes sénateur et l'ère des yvelines
alors audition publique c'est le rendez
vous du lundi soir une heure en direct
sur lcp public sénat avec le figaro une
image du jour c'est un ancien président
de la république devant les juges
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu cet après
midi au tribunal
il est poursuivi pour corruption on va
regarder par la corruption et trafic
d'influencé dans l' affaire dite des
écoutes
l'un des volets de l'enquêté sur le
financement de sa campagne
présidentielle en 2012
gérard larcher quand vous voyez celui
qui a été président de la république
issu de vos rangs danse devant un
tribunal
quels sentiments ça suscite chez d'abord
je suis pas chroniqueur judiciaire je
vais donc pas commenter le procès qui
vient de débuter un sentiment plutôt un
sentiment plutôt que vous de principe de
séparation même interdit de le fermer
ce procès a mis en lumière des pratiques
qui vont étonner si je reprends une
formule que j'ai entendu y compris dans
la bouche du garde des sceaux le système
des filets dérivants qui me permet à
partir d'une affaire de capter une autre
affaire moi je suis très attaché au
principe de la confiance entre
magistrats et avocats au respect du
secret de l'avocat et ma préoccupation
même si ça peut déplaire c'est de
préserver l'autorité de justice
et la confiance dans l'autorité de
justice un état de droit a besoin de
confiance dans l'autorité de justice et
c'est ça ma préoccupation
quand vous dites qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire exactement kiki keane qui
remet en cause l'état de droit il ya un
certain nombre de dossiers dans lequel
aujourd'hui l'autorité de justice est
interrogé je ne dis pas mise en cause
je crois qu'il ya besoin que nous
retrouvions cette relation entre
notamment des décideurs politiques et
l'autorité de justice sans confusion des
genres croître et de se les ventes et de
ce point de vue ce procès peut être
l'occasion de renouer la confiance entre
les gestes que la procédure suivie n'a
pas permis de renouer la confiance
regardez bien puisqu'il y a eu une
demande du président de la république
d'une enquête sur les agissements de
magistrat du parquet national qui a
conclu qu'il n'y avait rien il n'empêche
qu'il y a encore une enquête est donc
vraiment je ne souhaite pas aller plus
loin d'un nom et d'un sentiment de voir
nicolas bâtiment mon sentiment c'est que
notre pays a besoin d'une justice
sereine vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy
dont j'ai appartenu à sa majorité chacun
codé ma liberté par rapport à nicolas
sarkozy
je trouve que tout ça ne me correspond
pas à l'image et à ce qu'il a apporté au
pays il reste populaire à droite
certains aimeraient bien le voir revenir
d'ailleurs mais tout ça à la salle mais
définit un hors jeu
écoutez c'est pas le sujet je pense que
je fais confiance en la justice parce
que je dois dire que je pense que le
regardera si elle a les preuves ou si
elle n'a pas les preuves sans
intervention extérieure c'est ce que
vous avez dit on va poursuivre
maintenant avec mes consoeurs des
chaînes parlementaires brigitte boucher
de sp bonsoir brigitte mont cervin 6
sentra nuit de public sénat dont sortent
à brossard 36 s'avance et hamon va
commencer à charger les grenats virus
évidemment parce que ça c'est là encore
et toujours la préoccupation numéro un
des français est depuis des mois depuis
huit mois maintenant
gérard larcher le président emmanuel
macron va donc s'exprimer demain il va
s'exprimer pour apporter nous dit il de
la clarté donner un cap c'est ça
vous attendez c'est ce qui a manqué
jusqu'ici moi je pense que les français
ont besoin d'y voir clair ils ont besoin
de confiance quand je regarde le sondage
ifop du mois de novembre on voit que
simplement 39% d'entre eux ont confiance
il ya eu beaucoup d'approximations
beaucoup de l'absence de visibilité
il ya eu un certain nombre d'échecs un
jeu depuis le mois de mars sur les mains
vous ce matin c'était un objet rare je
vous rappelle et même dangereux
paraît-il en avril salle et resterez
tracé isolé chacun a le souvenir de
septembre des difficultés à se faire
tester et puis isolement chacun sait que
c'est notre maillon faible
et là c'est une responsabilité
collective et là je ne montre pas en
tant que tel l'exécutif mais l'important
demain du président de la république
c'est qu'ils fassent ça les français
s'interrogent qui parfois doute qui
parfois sont en colère parfois sont un
peu là est désespérée quelles stratégies
pour wigan sortie progressive du
déconfite banc juste y aller comme quel
calendrier ne veut pas employer ce mot
déconfinement il ne veut plus parler de
slide par les emplois deux changements
les contres agressive du confinement
oui allègement des contraintes élevées
mais très bientôt contrainte
il ya un moment il faudra bien qu'on ait
un incivisme collectif car il ne suffira
pas de contraintes comme chaque semaine
tout va être certainement décider le
matin en conseil de défense à ce que
c'est pour vous une instance légitime
qu'elle est légitime elle existe dans
nos institutions c'est le rôle et la
place du président de la république
je souhaite que ce soir et que le
parlement soit moins tenus à l'écart de
l'ensemble des décisions qui contribue à
la compréhension de ces décisions
voilà pourquoi j'ai insisté depuis trois
semaines tant auprès du président de la
république nous sommes vus il ya
maintenant 18 jours qu auprès du premier
ministre avant de parler des grands mots
unité nationale union nationale parlons
nous je pense que
l'absence d'associations du parlement ce
qui nous a été proposé pendant la loi
d'urgence
oui voilà que pendant sept mois on avait
des battus quatre fois on nous proposait
pour six mois de ne plus débat je pense
qu'il faut plus associer le parent c'est
sûr qu'on va y entendre des marques
voilà pourquoi j'ai tellement regret
mais le conseil de déco d'amendements
pardonnez-moi l'amendement 83 parce que
je les ai écrit au président de la
république au premier ministre du sénat
dans la loi d'urgence qui prévoyait pour
la question notamment de l'ouverture des
commerces que ça se fasse à partir du
préfet dans un dieu préféré aux ordres
du gouvernement
dans un dialogue avec les élus avec les
organisations professionnelles locales
ça me semblait une manière de gérer je
souhaite que dans ce processus de sortie
du confinement
on trouve la concertation qu'on ne
recommence pas que ma aix marseille
j'étais avec ce et sous préfète est pas
encore au courant que c'est la mesure
était entrée en application et il n'y
avait pas eu de concertation avec les
élus et je pense que c'est la voie qu'il
faut trouver et c'est une responsabilité
du du président de la république sur ce
qu'il va annoncer
alors vous l'avez la kz2 les mots il
faut qu'on réussisse et vous l'attendez
la sortie du 2ème confinement et puis
qu'ils nous ouvrent vers la stratégie
vaccinale
je vous entends sur l'amendement 83
justement est ce que pour vous la
priorité des priorités gérard larcher
c'est la réouverture des petits
commerces
l'abondement 83 c'était lille j'allais
dire ça aurait pu être l'illusion d'une
méthode et c'était la référence à une
méthode que nous proposions il ya bien
d'autres points
si j'ai choisi cet amendement 83 sexy en
a vaguement votée à l'unanimité au sénat
tous groupes confondus et que
l'assemblée nationale ne retient pas en
deuxième lecture qui était possible pour
le gouvernement de réintroduire après la
mise au jour de ce nom là verture des
commerces c'est extrêmement important
apportant d'abord pour l'équité entre
les différentes formes de distribution
important cette partie de l'année
essentiels pour l'activité commerciale
important pour envoyer aussi un signal
allez positif ça doit être d'aider c'est
ça l'essentiel
aujourd'hui si les conditions sanitaires
le permettent que nous retrouvions une
activité commerciale dans le coeur de
nos villes dans nos villages
c'est l'activité commerciale faut
entendre les petits commerces aux
également les restaurants et les bars
des sont fermés tout dépendra du
protocole sanitaire on sait que c'est
plus sensible dans les bars et dans les
restaurants les analyses qui sont faites
par les scientifiques par les
épidémiologistes le démontre donc si
nous commençons par le commerce au mois
de décembre dans des conditions à
définir l'allemagne a fait un autre
choix je vous le rappelle loi n'y a fait
le choix du nombre de mètres carrés par
commerce pour recevoir un client ya je
crois des procédures à définir ces
procédures doivent permettre un
redémarrage de l'activité commerce en
décembre où didier se faisait un peu de
temps je dis c'est ce que j'entends
est ce que je souhaite c'est ce que je
souhaite parce que on arrive dans un
mois qui est essentiel pour l'activité
commerciale mais l'essentiel aussi au
moral des français est ce que dans les
priorités vous mettez aussi la
réouverture des lieux de culte
j'ai demandé car c'est une liberté
fondamentale il faut quand même que nous
mesurions bien combien l'urgence
sanitaire nécessaire est en quelque
sorte attentatoires aux libertés
individuelles et collectives savez j'ai
rempli ma petite fiche larron battrai
pour aller dans la rue d'à côté j'ai
pris mes petites cases
je me suis dit pour aller dans la rue
gambetta qui n'est pas loin de chez moi
quand même voilà que je remplis un
papier qui peut être contrôlés à tout
moment et me poser la question pourquoi
je m'en vais dans la rue d'à côté et
c'est unique au monde à ses commandes
oui mais et c'est en même temps une
vraie question voilà pourquoi je suis
aussi exigeant sur le nécessaire
contrôle du parlement
quand on abandonne une telle liberté
celle de soutenir cette attestation
dérogatoire au nom au nom de la
protection de la santé
on oppose deux principes souvent on
oppose liberté sécurité publique
hélas ces libertés individuelles et
sécurité sanitaire il faut en permanence
que ça soit sous le contrôle du
parlement
et je crois que c'est une vraie exigence
vous plaidez pour la réouverture des
lieux de culte les rassemblements il y
en a eu hier à versailles devant des
églises est ce que vous dites et gérald
darmanin il faut faire appliquer la loi
il faut verbaliser
ces gens dit rien gérard banal mais je
vois que la question des cultes est une
liberté fondamentale si les conditions
sanitaires sont respectées je le
rappelle est je le rappelle avec ma
liberté vis-à-vis de l'église catholique
chacun le sait il suffit de regarder mon
cv que le temps de l'avent est un temps
important pour les chrétiens
et il faut aussi qu'on soit attentif à
cette liberté fondamentale qui est
contenu dans la loi de 1905
la loi doit protéger la foi donc que ce
soit pour les catholiques ou les
musulmans ou pour tout le monde lui pour
être clair gérard larcher vous avez tout
à l'heure commencé à parler des vaccins
vous êtes d'ailleurs prononcé pour le
vaccin obligatoire
est ce que vous le maintenez quand vous
voyez que plus de 50 % des français sont
méfiants parce que vous n'êtes pas un
petit peu déconnectée de ses fruits
parce que je pense que pour les vaccins
il faut anticiper concertée organisée
il faut donc que nous ayons une
pédagogie vis-à-vis des vaccins cette
pédagogie
elle repose bien sûr sur la sécurité
vaccinale mais aussi d'expliquer aux
français je pense que le président de la
république va sans doute entamer cette
explication
comment on s'approvisionne qu'elle
pourrait être demain le calendrier
prévisionnel quelle méthode de
vaccination
quels publics prioritaires qui sera
chargée de la vaccination mais vous
maintenez vous êtes toujours pour un
accès pour les jeux est terminé
si vous le voulez bien et plus les
français seront rassurés plus dur en
confiance je dois simplement c'est aussi
là encore un sondage ipsos dans 15 pays
j'allais dire membres de l'ue ces lieux
plus de 70 % de population se dit prête
à se vacciner
oui france à peine plus de 50%
nous avons donc un déficit de pédagogie
et de confiance
et pourquoi j'ai dit que si nous narre
vie n'arrivions pas créé qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon pardonner aux
vétérinaires
le matelas vaccinale il faudrait
peut-être en passer par la vaccination
obligatoire jusqu'au mans j'étais très
très marquée cédant 1 appartient à une
génération qui a connu la polio dans une
école qu'inconnu et la gto proximité
assez touché à proximité de la part de
gens que je connaissais extrêmement bien
et que pour moi se vacciner ce n'est pas
que pour soi même un élément de
solidarité collective et nous avons
besoin dans notre société
deux collectifs ça n'est pas simplement
moi c'est moi et les autres et les
autres et moi donc vaccination
obligatoire mais dans un dernier
deuxième temps ci les français le
contrôle du parlement
oui justement du parlement et fait la
question de temps mais tout d'abord
richard ferrand donc votre tout d'abord
est longue à l'assemblée veut saisir
l'office parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et techniques oui vous le
salut est très bonne il est d'accord
avec les labos solitaire le
vice-président sénat gérard longuet et
je suis certain que alors les méthodes
de l'office prennent en général plus de
temps mais je crois qu'un travail de
l'office parlementaire correspond tout à
fait aux missions de l'office
parlementaire après cela et vous de
l'évaluation je rappelle ceux qui nous
écoutent des choix scientifiques et
technologiques étaient des choix
scientifiques c'est important c'est
brigitte mais oui on pas parler de
sécurité globale et de cet article 24
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre et
interdit la diffusion d'image
malveillante de policiers en opérations
de maintien de l'ordre
cet article 24 braque la presse est ce
que vous comprenez vous que les
journalistes y voit là une atteinte
à la liberté d'informer d'abord le sujet
c'est une vision de la sécurité
intérieure il ya maintenant plus de deux
ans gérard collomb à leur ministre
d'état ministre de l'intérieur nous
avait annoncé un livre blanc un projet
global et il faut un continuum de
sécurité qu'ils aillent du maire jusqu'à
la justice en passant par les policiers
qu'ils soient municipaux nationaux
gendarmerie voici société de sécurité
privée
c'est tout ça ce texte et ce qui est
souhaité de faire regarder la situation
avant qu'on parle du débat sur l'article
24 ans 15 ans 81% d'agression policiers
en plus en 10 ans plus de 70%
d'agressions de gendarmes en plus et un
rapport patrick kanner catherine 32 l'an
dernier sur les sapeurs-pompiers 210% je
crois même que c'est 213% de plus
d'agressions en disant il faut donc on
est une réponse
alors d'accord ça c'est la journée des
réponses parce que nous devons est un
état de droit et les acteurs de l'état
de droit
ce sont les policiers a dit la réponse
globale gérald lesigne rythme et la met
sur la journaliste sur l'article 20 et
surtout sur les journalistes vous êtes
bien vu que ça crée de l'émotion chez
genre fsma vous comprenez ça 24 lui même
quand on regarde cet article dans la
rédaction
tel qu'il sort des travaux de
l'assemblée nationale nous voyons que ce
qui est visé c'est l'utilisation d'image
aux fins de faire pression physique et
psychologique sur des policiers ou des
gendarmes et notamment par des messages
qui manifestement veulent pas simplement
les dénoncer mais s'en prendre
directement à eux mêmes ou à leur
famille en mettant des adresses
c'est ce type de message qui est visé
oui mais ce que dit
aujourd'hui dans la rédaction les
confrères donc pas d'inquiétude de ce
faire nous aurons peut-être à préciser
dans le débat au sénat
le moment venu qui est sous le statut de
la loi de 1881
ça doit conforter les journalistes me
semble-t-il est respecté leur mission
qui est de d'informer en toute liberté
il faut préciser ça c'est ce que vous
dites au sénat il faudrait que vous
regardez c'est l'intérêt du bicamérisme
d'accord donc on a beaucoup débattu
renée oublier la situation des policiers
des gendarmes bien savez moi je veux le
dire quand même je suis l'élu du
département où un couple de policiers a
été assassiné dans sa maison devant
l'enfant ce n'était pas les réseaux
sociaux mais c'était une forme de
filature qui a ressemblé et la filature
par les réseaux sociaux nécessite que
nous protégions policiers gendarmes
n'oublions pas ces drames et et lyon le
hawker bien on va parler d'un mot du
projet de loi sur le séparatisme ça
s'appelle comme ça ça ne s'appelle plus
comme ça tape ça va s'appeler de pour
congédier les principes républicains
républicain effectivement aujourd'hui
pour vous qu'est ce qui fragilise
aujourd'hui les principes républicains
vous avez eu ce texte entre les mains
est ce que vous pensez et bien qu'il qui
répond vraiment pour vous et bien à ce
qui menace aujourd'hui ces principes
républicains à ce que ça aurait pu aussi
éviter l'assassinât de sa mère pattie
c'est un projet de loi qui vise à lutter
clairement appelons les mots contre
l'islam radical et j'insiste sur le mot
radical parce que islamo islamistes ça
ne veut pas dire on soit quelque chose
qui est négative parce que
personnellement je pense que les
musulmans de france doivent pouvoir
vivre leur foi dans la vie publique sa
mémoire avec marcel gaucher nous avons
produit un opuscule de réflexion en 2019
est possible c'est brillant je disais
tout à l'heure
arina loi aristide briand la loi doit
protéger la foi tant que la fois
n'entend pas dicter la noue autour de ça
il ya des propositions pour la
neutralité du service public pour les
activités associatives pour la dignité
des hommes et des femmes il y a des
propositions pour l'éducation la lutte
c'est complexe
ça nous renvoie à la haine en ligne se
mouiller renvoie à notre article 24 et
c'est un article d'ailleurs qui portent
les numéros 25 et 26 dans le projet de
loi et puis il renvoie l'accession
liberté et de l'organisation des cultes
notamment pour le contrôle
chose parce que tam vous poser la
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui qui
fragilise aujourd'hui les principes
républicains eh bien le fait qu' un
certain nombre
j'allais dire de prédicateurs et pas
simplement religieux ou d'acteurs pense
qu' elle noie supérieur la loi de la
république ils sont n'y a aucune loi
quels qu'ils soient de l'intérieur à la
loi de la république brigitte pour
fonder un islam de france l'islam des
lumières dit emmanuel macron est ce que
c'est bien de s'appuyer sur le cfcm qui
doit labellisé finalement les imams de
france en salle français du culte
musulman
le conseil français du culte musulman
elle mérite d'exister
il est là a été construit lady ristori
demande de pierre joxe en passant par
jean pierre chevènement puis nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande et il a une
légitimité
ce conseil français du culte musulman il
est une organisation des musulmans entre
eux il lui appartient de déterminer les
conditions dans lequel le libre exercice
du culte musulman peut se faire dans les
valeurs de l'argent mais quand je
voudrai il aura l'autorité sur
l'ensemble des musulmans pour le faire
il acquerra progressivement
pardonnez moi si on reprend l'histoire
ça n'a pas été si simple dans les
rapports entre la république l'église
piétons que ça n'a pas été si simple
il ya un peu plus de deux siècles dans
l'organisation des relations avec le
judaïsme et le protestantisme et bien la
république se doit aujourd'hui de
permettre à nos compatriotes musulmans
d'exercice il le souhaite sa vie c'est
le droit de croire ou de ne pas croire
juste pour terminer ses dents pour
terminer sur ce sujet c'est très simple
est-ce que c'est donc au conseil
français du culte musulman
qui pratiquent en coûtait comme il l'est
pour la fédération protestante de france
d'agréer des pasteurs vais raconter ce
que nous acceptons pour d'autres cultes
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi on
mettrait en doute la capacité à pasteur
c'est à gré c'est l'évêque qui désigne
dans le diocèse
le prêtre ou deux diacres donc organiser
le culte par contre contrôler d'où
l'importance du statut 1905
en 1901 je crois que ces sujets il faut
les voir avec exigence depuis trente ans
n'a reculé on a reculé notamment
vis-à-vis de l'islamisme radical du
rapport obin aux territoires perdus de
la république au drame de conflent là
encore dans mon département ou dans
celui de nice je vous dis la république
a reculé bien on va conclure là dessus
pour ce soir en tout cas parce
qu'évidemment le débat il va avoir lieu
pendant des semaines et des mois
merci brigitte et merci tu as réal annie
prochain bien évidemment à venir lycéens
sais pas si vous aviez entendu parler de
ça mais je crois personnellement je
connaissais pas trop avant pour tout
pour tout vous dire il a été financé et
créer en ligne directe avec le ministère
de l'éducation nationale en tout cas
c'est ce que dit médiapart et libération
à partir de témoignages d'anciens
adhérents jean michel blanquer se
retrouve accusée d'avoir favorisé la
création centre de ce syndicat et cet
après midi vous allez voir il s'en est
défendu c'est un non-sujet montée en
épingle par le secteur de mithra gauche
pour des raisons qui leur appartiennent
cette association c'est pas des
syndicats a été la première élue c'est à
dire elle a obtenu le plus de suffrages
au conseil supérieur de l'éducation il
ya maintenant je crois deux ou trois ans
c'est pas des sujets que je suis de très
très d'ailleurs et elle a obtenu une
subvention moindre d'ailleurs que
d'autres qui avaient le même genre de
score les années d'avant
donc voilà elle a eu une subvention
aujourd'hui le sujet c'est est ce que l
on a fait un mauvais usage
c'est dès que j'ai su qu'il y avait un
éventuel problème on a diligenté une
enquête
cette enquête évidemment cela donnera
les résultats de manière complètement
transparente voilà le sujet alors gérard
larcher il ya deux thèses dans comment
on fait pour avoir la vérité une
commission d enquête parlementaire
et si l'assemblée nationale le décide
elle peut toujours le faire
bré que chacun mesure bien les relations
qu'ils avec les associations étudiantes
avant de se lancer dans ce genre
d'opération moi je fais confiance à
priori au be nice mais le rôle du
parlement c'est de contrôler et gardien
scandaleuse qui est un contrôle
parlement si c'était au sénat en
commission d enquête parlementaire au
sénat
écoutez je crois que c'était l'assemblée
nationale que cela vous arrange non cela
arrange pas je pense qu'on a démontré en
matière de com offre est la question
pardonnez moi nous allions quand les
choses étaient importantes au bout des
choses
d'accord vous disiez les relations
autrefois entre certains partis
politiques et syndicats étudiants est-ce
que les erreurs du passé justifie sa nos
jours dit mais non mais je ne je fais
plutôt confiance au ministre et je ne
suis pas suspect ne le supportait matin
midi et soir yves thréard et avec nos
bons soir yves et on va parler de
politique aussi avec vous et gérard
larcher
alors je voudrais au nom d'un p'tit
droit de suite veut revenir sur le tout
début de l'émission sur la sphère
sarkozy non pas sur le fond mais sur
quelque chose dont on parle assez peu le
juge d'instruction qui a instruit cette
affaire s'appelle serge tournaire
il se trouve que ce juge il a instruit
cette affaire il a instruit la sphère
big ben à lyon il a inscrit ce fruit d'
affaire tapie il a instruit d'affaires
fillon il a instruit la sphère des
financements présumer ou supposer libyen
est ce que vous trouvez pas qu'il ya une
anomalie à ce qu'un juge d'instruction
soit au coeur de toutes les affaires
politico judiciaires en france c'est un
sujet pour le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature estimé mais tous ces sujets
et d'ailleurs le rôle du contrôle du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature est
essentiel et je dois dire que peut-être
que ce contrôle nécessiterait d'être
réactualisé moment on parle depuis
longtemps il ya eu un accord entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sur la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et sur notamment les avis
qu'il doit donner
je crois qu'il ya là un vrai sujet car
j'insiste
si on ne retrouve pas confiance dans la
justice et une partie de l'état de droit
qui sera affaiblie et moi
personnellement
veut faire confiance dans l'autorité de
justice à peux pas dire que je n'ai pas
des exigences par rapport à l'autorité
de justice et pardonnez moi c'est
vraiment le rôle du conseil supérieur
tout autre sujet c'est le vote par
correspondance vous êtes prononcés pour
est-ce que ce vote par correspondance
doit s'appliquer dès maintenant pour les
élections régionales et départementales
du mois de juin
je suis né sur je ne suis pas encore
prononcé pour car j'attends le résultat
de la mission flash que la commission
des lois a mis en place cette mise en
place doit nous donner avant noël
ces conclusions il ne s'agit pas
simplement de parler du vote par
correspondance
il s'agit de voir dans les conditions
sanitaires que nous connaissons si nous
pouvons adapter adapter notre code
électoral nous l'avons déjà fait au
printemps avec la double procuration
mais c'était une semaine avant le
deuxième tour la vraie alors avoir le
recul réfléchir aussi est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas donner une autre procuration
par exemple à quelqu'un qui n'habitent
pas dans la commune il ya l'organisation
des bureaux de vote même car nous allons
avoir une élection synchrone
départementales et régionales et vous ça
il ya des locaux de mairie et pas que
dans les petites communes
ils sont exigus rentrée difficile les
gestes barrière ni terre et les règles
sanitaires les gestes barrière il y à
aussi l'organisation de la campagne
est ce que il ne faut pas imaginer une
campagne un peu différente avec une part
de virtualité il y a la durée de la
campagne et les comptes de campagne et
il ya le vote par correspondance et par
internet derrière aussi on n'en est pas
là on ne pouvait y aller
l'accord au nom va étudier le scrutin
électronique mais je ne pense pas mais
il faut rien laisser de conilhac ordre
a2 qui suivra même la fiabilité la
fiabilité
j'allais dire c'est à dire l'exercice
plein et entier de la liberté de choix
de l'électeur pour qu'il n'y ait pas
pression sur lui active
je rappelle que le vote par
correspondance on le pratique pour les
français établis hors de france
d'avoir partie d'entre eux est le second
sujet c'est pour le second tour les
choses ne sont pas de simples c'est la
fiabilité postale parce que vous êtes
par exemple dans des élections
régionales il peut y avoir des fusions
de listes les déposé le mardi
comment on fait pour voter le dimanche
et voilà ça n'a jamais été pointé du
nord précisément parce qu'on crée c'est
concret du vécu c'est concret et j'avais
les rives ans avant d'avoir un avis
définitive
alors je veux parler des régionales et
départementales en ile-de-france qui est
votre région aussi élective est ce que
vous allez appeler à voter vous
président du sénat membre des
républicains pour valérie pécresse qui
n'est plus aux républicains
savez vous que je vous donnais un scoop
je vais sans doute à nouveau président
et son comité de soutien en ile de
france et elle me l'a demandé
pour tout vous avouer je lui ai répondu
positivement la semaine dernière donc
parce qu'elle fait de l'excellent
travail
oui dans notre région ile-de-france sur
des choses de fond développement
environnement sur ces sujets il fait du
concret mais aussi la vie quotidienne
des franciliens les conditions de
transport qui était une catastrophe je
dis pas que tout est encore aujourd'hui
idéal elle les a beaucoup amélioré le
suivi la présence le soutien
pardonnez-moi à l'agriculture et
notamment à la transition agricole en
ile de france elle est extrêmement
pauvre à faire sa campagne ce sera vous
êtes fait sa compagne parce que j'ai un
visage de villo les chronos pour dire
que ces régionales à droite qui est
votre votre camp peuvent servir de
primaire justement avant l'élection plan
d'ensemble de 2022 sont pas candidats
aux élections revanche il ya un mot que
vous avez prononcé et moi j'aimerais
bien que vous nous définissions plus
façon plus précise
c'est le départage c'est quoi le
départage dont la présidence a géré la
présidentielle d'abord partie d'une
observation politiques chérif traire
est ce que on considère que dans
l'espace politique
situé entre la république en marche et
le rassemblement national
oui entre emmanuel macron et marine le
pen
il n'y a rien je ne le pense pas je
pense que nous avons une responsabilité
particulière de proposer une alternative
aux français
et cette alternative c'est pas entre
macron et le pen ou de même pour les
sociaux-démocrates je pense qu'il ya une
alternative à proposer
emmanuel macron mélenchon c'est donc une
responsabilité démocratique mais nous
savons aussi que si nous avons deux
candidats au premier tour dans cet
espace
je parle de l'espace auquel j'appartiens
nous ne serons pas présents au second
tour et là vous m'avez ah voilà pourquoi
pas répondu je propose et ils n'aiment
pas ça ne répond pas de départage c'est
à dire de trouver dans un dialogue avec
les candidats ça c'est par l'intérieur
des républicains comme à l'extérieur de
républicains des deux présidents de
région quelle vous pensiez lavier
bertrand par exemple est un tps rang de
favori des républicains même si l'on
partage beaucoup des valeurs et les
centristes
il ya aussi des familles centristes
c'est avec tout cela que je veux en lien
avec plus sur jacob en lien avec ma
famille politique mais pas uniquement
d'accord dans ma famille politique
collectivement trouvé la méthode de
départager le faire yves dans les
premières semaines de l'an prochain pour
que nous soyons prêts donc à l'issue des
élections départementales et régionales
eh bien nous choisissions une candidate
ou un candidat gérard larcher nettement
les partis qui choisissent ça c'est ma
vision gaulliste et attendez il ya une
question qui nous soutenons mais gérard
larcher va nous donner la méthode donc
dû départager début janvier c'est ce que
je n'attends début janvier dans les
premières semaines que j'ai parlé du
printemps et je ne vois pas le printemps
janvier c'est mon côté paysan dans les
premières semaines jours
on va revenir dans les premières
semaines de noël on a pas compris dans
les premières semaines de du coup le
printemps c'est-à-dire avril
je n'ai pas d'attenté printemps c'est le
21 mars
je n'ai pas de date en tête 36 ans et je
pense qu'il faut l'avoir préparé il faut
en avoir débattu pour réalimenter les
départements de nom de nom et oui les
dernières espérances pour chaque nom va
vite un homme qui a beaucoup de succès
aujourd'hui au moins médiatiquement que
vous connaissez bien qu'ils s'appellent
pierre de villiers ancien chef de l'état
major des armées
on parle de lui justement pour peut-être
figurer à cette présidentielle
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec une
expression qu'il a en tête qu'il a
formulées ya pas très longtemps disant
que la france
ils répondent à une consoeur était au
bord de la quête de la guerre civile
je suis un peu plus optimiste que pierre
de villiers
je pense que la france est en état de
fractures le fracture communautaire par
exemple de fractures territoriales entre
la france des métropoles et la france
des petites villes des villes moyennes
de l'espace rural fracture communautaire
nous l'évoquions tout à l'heure quand
nous évoquions les valeurs de la
république et s'est fracturé la peuvent
conduire à terme à des violences et
d'ailleurs nous avons déjà des violences
quand je vais dans mon département un
bus incendié à montesson alors que le
chauffeur est seul ce sont des violences
strictement inacceptable or sur pierre
de villiers
s'il souhaite être candidat mais j'ai
entendu dire qu'il n'était pas candidat
à 6 mais s'ils le souhaitent et s'ils le
souhaitent de partage bien sûr à lambres
ancien porte ouverte c'est pas c'est pas
ton bat ouvert pour tout cas prenez bien
c'est pas un jeu c'est pas le départage
une succession c'est d'offrir aux
françaises et aux français une
alternative vient alors une dernière
question pour y faire une impression
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien aussi
nicolas dupont aignan qui est bien a
exprimé le désir
de revenir dans le giron de la famille
des républicains est-ce que vous
l'accueillez avec grand coeur n'ont pas
grand coeur parce que je n'oublie pas le
choix qu'il a faits de marine le pen au
second tour et il faudrait que nicolas
dupont aignan révise un certain nombre
de ces conceptions de manière profonde
donc il fallait bien parce que je n'ai
pas d'hostilité personnel à son égard
mais je dois dire que ces choix ne sont
pas les miens donc il n'a rien à faire
dans ce départ et les miens et que
pardonnez moi on juge un homme ou une
femme politique à des choix dans des
moments essentiels
donc il n'est pas une élection
présidentielle c'est un choix essentiel
ni un saint éligibles au départage donc
il ne me semble pas qu en l'état
merci merci monsieur le président merci
francis à lundi vous êtes le bienvenu
sur ce plateau et vit d'abord vous êtes
c'est vous aussi vous lui toujours
alors vous savez que merci gérard
larcher il va y avoir un délit déco site
qui va être créée dans la prochaine loi
sur la transition écologique qui
renforcera des sanctions financières et
pourra même aller jusqu'à des peines de
prison pour des personnes ou des
entreprises qui ont volontairement
polluer un site par exemple et barbara
pompéi a même déclaré ce matin sur
france info le glaive de la justice va
s'abattre sur les bandits de
l'environnement voilà ce qu'est la vie
avec eric dupond-moretti on a mis en
place et on va le faire voter dans la
loi la semaine prochaine un grand délit
qui est un des 10 qui va permettre de
faire payer tout ce qu'ils soient sans
le faire exprès soit parce qu'ils l'ont
voulue et parce qu'ils l'ont fait exprès
porte des atteintes à l'environnement si
jamais on abîme l'environnement eh bien
on sera condamné là on peut aller
jusqu'à quatre millions cinq d'amande et
10 ans de prison
gérard larcher c'est une vraie avancée
se délient des quotités deux fois en
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat ont
repoussé des propositions de loi qui
portait sur la création de délit d'
écocide je dois dire que dans le code de
l'environnement depuis 2016 on a le
préjudice écologique et que à vouloir
bouger le code en permanence je ne suis
pas certain que ronde totalement service
à la cause
on veut poursuivre faudra voir quelle
est la nature du texte
vous avez vu qu'il ya dire pour le moins
il faut aussi améliorer nos nos moyens
de contrôle il ya aussi les sanctions
administratives
j'ai tout ça suffit ces formules lancé
comme ça
la prudence fait que je veux voir le
texte et que nous le jugerons le moment
venu et tout temps a priori mais je
rappelle quand même que deux fois l'an
dernier des propositions de loi créant
ce dédit déco side ont été repoussés
aussi bien par l'assemblée nationale que
par le sénat bien on va cueillir je le
salue mes deux collègues à bien attendez
on va les accueillir si vous voulez bien
maintenant qu'ils sont arrivés sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
en effet gérard larcher il ya deux
parlementaires en phase de mou pour
débattre avec vous ce soir alors je fais
toujours parfait bêtise pierre laurent
bonsoir où s'étaient pressés vous vous
êtes sénateur le pcf de paris
vice président du sénat vous avez été
aussi à la tête du parti communiste
pendant quelques années et bonsoir
marine aux arcs
vous êtes député la république en marge
des yvelines donc le même département
que gérard larcher député la république
en gésine je disais première
vice-présidente du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale alors vos collègues sont venus
avec des questions précises et pierre
laurent voudrais d'abord vous interroger
sur le rôle du parlement vous l'avais un
peu évoquée en cette période de co vide
oui moi je suis très inquiet de l'état
démocratique du pays on va on aura vécu
au printemps avec la prolongation on
aura vécu un an sous état d'urgence
c'est pas la première fois en plus pour
des raisons différentes dans les années
dans les années écoulées et le
rapporteur de la commission des lois au
sénat lodger parlait de 80 ordonnance
dans l'année c'est c'est du jamais vu
sous la vème république c'est à dire on
gouverne vraiment nous on appelle ça une
monarchie présidentielle
on peut discuter les termes mais en tout
cas on est dans une situation de
privation de
du rôle plein du parlement moi je parle
de confinement du parlement même si on
continue de fonctionner mais la
démocratie est mal en point je moi je
suis très inquiet de ça on n'écoute pas
beaucoup les citoyens on l'a vu sur
l'hôpital où les alertes avaient précédé
la crise du coc vide on n'écoute pas
beau lui beaucoup les élus locaux on le
voit encore avec l'appel des 110 mère
qui sont obligés de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
on n'écoute pas assez le parlement ça
fait beaucoup et moi je pense qu'il
faudrait un peu tapé du poing sur la
table sur cette question démocratique
extrêmement qui est en parfait je crois
que pierre laurent sur la question des
ordonnances et souligne un aspect
extrêmement importants dont j'ai parlé
au président de la république il ya un
peu plus de deux semaines
depuis mai 2007
206 ordonnance nous en avons déjà passé
rien que sur la crise sanitaire est
souvent les ordonnances prennent plus de
temps à sortir que le texte dont on
aurait eu à débattre
nous avons une décision du conseil
constitutionnel en mai de cette année
qui dit que l' ordonnance
quand elle est prise après le texte
d'habilitation n'a pas besoin de la
ratification après un certain délai pour
devenir j'allais dire un principe
intangible dans la loi ce qui choque le
contrôle démocratique du parlement
voilà pourquoi j'ai proposé jeu nous
allons mettre en place à partir
d'ailleurs du 16 décembre groupe de
travail qui notamment aura à mettre en
place la cellule de veille sur les
antennes ans pour astreindre à ce qu'est
une ratification mais je le disais au
président de la république on ne peut
pas continuer dans un parlement qui est
chad et qui et chattez et qui ne débat
pas est que là le concept des
ordonnances et naturellement à
l'affaiblissement démocratique mais
pierre laurent a souligné un autre
aspect sept mois nous avons débattu
quatre fois de la loi d'urgence et là on
nous a demandé de plus en débattre
jusqu'au printemps
alors qu' il y à la nécessité d'un
contrôle démocratique pendant une
période pierre seulement
dick de nos libertés absolument le
parlement le parlement à bic de ses
droits en fin mais c'est le travail à
partir du 16 décembre
c'est une avancée pour vous oui mais on
voit bien que ça suffit pas parce que ce
qu'il faut mettre en cause là maintenant
on sait toujours nécessaire parce qu'il
faut et il faut malgré les entraves
essayer d'exercer le contrôle du
parlement mais et c'est surtout qu'il
faut il faut cesser avec ce système
parce que si on prolonge et durablement
ça parce que on sait que tout un tas de
dispositions prises en dessous l'état
d'urgence perdure elle rentre ensuite
dans droit commun on s'habitue on est en
train de prendre de très mauvaises
habitudes démocratique et je pense que
il faut je le disais moi je pense qu'il
faut maintenant un peu tapé du poing sur
la table parce que sinon on va
s'habituer et les présidents de la
république celui là et d'autres peuvent
s'habituer à ce mode de gouvernement en
mars et vous allez faire extrêmement
solitaire
c'est ce qui est en train de se faire je
les dis clairement dans mon discours du
1er octobre devant l'ensemble des
sénateurs qui est qu'ils aient voté pour
moi qu'il n'ait pas voté pour moi je
sais que ce sujet il est majeur pour les
droits du parlement et plus nous vivons
une période difficile plus il faut se
parler entre l'exécutif et le parlement
avant de parler d'unité nationale
l'union nationale parlons nous et je
pense que c'est tout à fait essentielle
vient de se parler et d'échanger et en
tous les cas sur les ordonnances
j'espère que nous pourrons apporter un
certain nombre de réponses et en même
temps d'être vigilant au plan de la
tentation de l'ordonance parce que de
l'ordonance au décret doit il n'y a pas
de tant de chemin que ça marie le bec
marie le bec
vous voulez parler avec le président du
sénat à la chambre des collectivités
territoriales justement de collectivités
territoriales et puisqu'on parle de
responsabilité
pierre laurent pas réduire la
responsabilité du président du sénat
vous aussi vous voulez parler une
certaine responsabilité
merci monsieur le président c'est moins
une question qu'une invitation à
débattre finalement l'objet de ma
première intervention ce soir et je vous
rejoins sur la nécessité de se parler
avant de parler
l'unité nationale mais pour autant
depuis le début de cette crise je
constate que ce soit certaine opposition
au parlement mais aussi l'attitude de
certaines collectivités qui dont vous
êtes un des uns des représentants
puisque vous êtes le président du sénat
qui préfère finalement taper
systématiquement sur l'état considérant
qu'elle serait probablement l'échelle la
plus adaptée pour mieux gérer cette
crise mais qui aussi sont dans une
logique un peu de leçons constante qui
sont adressées au gouvernement qui
considère un temps que les mesures sont
trop strictes puisqu'elle sont trop
souple et puis qu'il faudrait une
logique territoriale mais que la logique
territoriale elle conduit à finalement
une forme de cacophonie au niveau
national qui rend un peu cette situation
ingérable
moi je crois que cette attitude de la
part des oppositions parlementaires mais
aussi des collectivités dans les
territoires elle affaiblit
dramatiquement le discours qui
voudraient pourtant est un discours ou
que l'on porte collectivement non pas
dans un souci d'unité nationale mais
vraiment dans un souci d'avoir les
français qui s'emparent aussi bien de
cette lutte contre le virus
j'entends dans votre partie des voix qui
s'élèvent contre la critique permanente
je pense à nicolas sarkozy à jean pierre
raffarin est ce que finalement le rôle
des collectivités le rôle d opposition
au parlement ce ne serait pas non pas
d'être dans une logique d'unité
nationale mais d'être dans une logique
un peu de caisse de résonance de
l'action qui est menée pour à lutter
contre ces virus d'avoir regardons ce
qui s'est passé au printemps
si nous n'avions pas eu la commune en
proximité dans l'immédiateté
nous n'avions pas eu départements et
régions comment aurait-on traverser ce
moment à la fois de peur de doute de
restriction des libertés qu'a représenté
la première phase de la première loi
d'urgence
c'est sur les collectivités et dans un
dialogue avec l'êta d'ailleurs parce que
dans le concret si je prends nous sommes
tous les deux issus du même département
il ya eu un dialogue entre notre agent
serait régionale de santé
les préfets et les collectivités
territoriales présentée de manière
caricaturale ces relations
mais nous avons besoin de plus de
proximité de
plus de confiance est d'ailleurs le
premier ministre dans son discours de
politique générale a prononcé plus de 30
fois le mot territoire et donc tenté
d'opposer les uns aux autres mais que
les territoires soient exigeants quand
je vais à aix marseille
premier moment une phase de re
confinement j'arrive à aix j'étais pas
là pourquoi je faisais de l'agit-prop
pour faire élire des sénateurs alors
quand je suis bon c'est bon bergeron il
connaît bien ça c'est d'autres voiliers
de l'agenda mais davantage et je
découvre une décision dans le cas des
cellules n'avaient pas été associés à
leurs maris le bec à aix marseille et le
premier ministre aujourd'hui entend bien
avoir une démarche d'association c'est
en tous les cas ce que je souhaite
tenter de nous opposer les uns aux
autres oui mais marival et moi c'est
vous qui en faisait dans la région ile
de france dans la région d'île de france
la région elle-même collectivités
territoriales jouets important un rôle
important à un moment alors tu as été
défait par rapport aux indispensables
aux gestes barrières qui était le port
d'un maillot et adam ii messieurs
président vous êtes juste pour rire
c'est le sens de mon cou n'est
absolument pas ni de dire que les
combats de l'activité ne sont pas en
capacité de gérer et effectivement je
pense que le premier ministre donne des
gages de confiance vis-à-vis des
territoires il l'a fait dans son
discours de politique générale mais si
on reprend cet exemple d'aix-marseille
et sans qu'à lire l'écriture et la
situation on a quand même été face à une
situation on avait des élus qui nous
expliquer que non il ne fallait pas
fermer les bars et les restaurants et
qui quelques heures après expliqué que
bah oui finalement la situation
sanitaire s'est tellement dégradée que
il fallait peut-être le faire mais
est-ce que j'ai assez vous voyez c'est
aussi se contredit secours permanent
mais s'il n'était pas allé parler se
parler c'est échanger des arguments
entendre et à certains moments il ya des
décisions qui ne plaisent pas qu'on
accepte et je crois que c'est vraiment
la proximité dont on a besoin et en même
temps du dialogue
entre l'exécutif le législatif et les
élus territoriaux mais bien en tout cas
allant pierre leur empire lors rien il
ya un autre sujet que voulait évoquer
c'est quelque chose qui vous reste en
travers de la gorge
c'est ce que les sénateurs les
républicains le parti de gérard larcher
ont voté comme ça au passage la retraite
à 63 ans mais non j'ai été scandalisé
par cet événement qui s'est produit à la
toute fin du débat sur le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale au
sénat et les sénateurs les républicains
ont fait voter au dernier moment
catimini un article pour réintroduire
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale l'allongement de la
retraite alors moi je trouvais sur la
forme scandaleux d'avoir fait ça parce
que alors que ce débat est sorti par la
grande porte je dirais pour le moment là
c'était le ramener par la petite porte
de manière assez incroyable
et puis sur le fond parce qu'on connaît
on est dans une période d'inquiétude
sociale majeure
il ya des préoccupations sociales à tous
les niveaux les jeunes ne vont pas
réussir encore moins qu'avant à rentrer
sur le marché du travail
la situation est très inquiétante et ont
réintroduit ça comme ça je dirais en
loucedé alors soit c'est la provocation
soit c'est de l'inconscience soit celle
annonce d'un programme
c'est le programme de la droite à la
présidentielle ça va être de dire aux
français maintenant il ya eu la pandémie
maintenant vous allez payer c'est vous
qui allez payer quoi de la provocation
d'abord peut-être première des choses le
loucedé c'est en fait la répétition de
deux années de deux votes du ep les
fléchettes donc ce n'est pas une
découverte
auger douala courbet lancement avec la
sécurité sociale enfin ça sur nous le
monde
on a un sujet nous allons avoir 17
milliards de déficit
notre système de retraite en 2001 20
milliards en 2024 ou bien se poser la
question de l'arbitrage entre
cotisations
niveau durée et niveau de pension et que
ce sujet dans l'amendement puisque vous
l'avez lu jusqu'au bout
il est proposé une conférence
de financement avec les partenaires
sociaux ce qui m'amène à rappeler à mes
deux collègues que nous sommes toujours
son 49,3 en matière de réforme des
retraites que le 49-3 été décidée en
conseil des ministres en février dernier
le même jour d'ailleurs on prenait les
premières mesures sur la pandémie de co
vite vous rires il ya quelques jours non
il y avait que le coc vide à l'ordre du
jour oui venez vous le cajon n'était pas
ce qu'il est arrivé seulement il ya les
ordonnances mais en plus elle est donc
on est toujours sur 43 je pense que les
collègues de la commission des affaires
sociales dans leur majorité ont voulu
attirer l'attention sur ce sujet de la
réforme des retraites de la situer pour
dire le paiement doit reprendre la
qualité de nos caisses de retraite et
sincèrement il était tard mais c'est pas
une surprise ça faisait deux ans que le
même en amendement était proposé on y
avait simplement ajouté je parle mais
les jeux parle l'élection je ne vote pas
en regardant la conférence de
financement mais les urgences du moment
sont quand même bien ailleurs
je lis les yeux réintroduire sa de cette
manière là si on veut ouvrir le débat
sur la confiance sur le financement
futur des retraites
ouvrons le mais ouvrons le sérieusement
pas de cette manière et ce probablement
parce que les recettes que 1 croit ce
prix d'ouverture du rapporteur général
et de la présidente de la commission bon
mari marie le bec ou toujours à propos
de la crise on est en plein dedans parce
que l'état va mettre beaucoup d'argent
sur la table il ya le plan de relance
mais pas seulement il ya aussi les aides
des aides qui vont aller aussi aux
collectivités locales est là aussi vous
demander au président gérard larcher de
se mouiller et j'allais dire je pense
que sur le volet économique de
de la gestion de cette crise on a
beaucoup parlé de la question de la
gestion sanitaire mais je suis avant
d'aller à la république en marche
issu de la même famille politique que
vous et je suis finalement un peu frappé
par parfois le positionnement un petit
peu défaitiste de responsables
politiques issus issus de la droite
j'ai trouvé que dans ces moments de
crise alors que justement qu'en termes
économiques on devrait faire preuve
d'adaptation collective une forme
d'abandon de l'idée de souveraineté de
l'idée de patriotisme de l'idée de faire
bouger les lignes et par la volonté
collective par la volonté du responsable
politique et par le comportement des
citoyens
moi j'ai peut-être quelques exemples à
vous donner on a alors un seul parent
peut-être celui qui consistait à
considérer que les commerces ne pouvait
pas se digitalise et ceux numérisés que
les français allaient forcément aller
consommer sur sur amazon et qu' on ne
pourrait pas faire bouger le bla le bar
le black friday 2 par les mesures
d'accompagnement économique qui ont été
prises qui permettent de soutenir les
entreprises de l'est digitalisées de par
les négociations qui ont été engagés par
le ministre de l'économie
on voit bien que en tant que responsable
politique on est en capacité de faire
bouger les lignes
encore une fois c'est mon sens une
question qu'une invitation à débattre
mais j'avais eu cette autorisation la
positionnement peut-être sur la façon
dont tu as pris vie économique cette
crise a été gérée a permis aussi de
répondre à un certain nombre de défis de
protéger nos entreprises et
d'accompagner les salariés dans cette
crise je crois que par exemple
l'utilisation du chômage partiel c'est
un ancien ministre du travail qui vous
le dit a été une très bonne initiative
qu'elle doit être encore accompagné que
le soutien certains noms d'entreprises
mais vous parliez de la digitalisation
vous mesurez bien que ce n'est pas en
quelques semaines qu'à commerces
indépendants qui n'est digitalisées qu'à
30% de se mettre en place
si vous n'aviez part si vous n'aviez pas
d'initiatives locales dans notre
département l'initiative de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie l'initiative
à rambouillet ma ville de la
municipalité pour mettre en place des
plateformes pour ces commerçants
voilà des vrais il ya aussi des réalités
dans cette crise parler beaucoup
d'entreprises
je suis très inquiet de l'émergence
d'une pauvreté de gens qui aujourd'hui
face à la crise je pense à ceux qui sont
dans ce qu'on appelle les permis tant
ceux qui ont des contrats précaires mais
pas uniquement dans un certain nombre de
secteurs d'activité que nous voyons
aller vers la pauvre avec de parler
souveraineté mais il ya aussi des choses
quotidiennes sur lequel il faut que nous
répondions quand le sénat vote une
taxation du e-commerce commerçants livre
et oui commerce en ligne pour soutenir
les commerces indépendants il fait tout
simplement une oeuvre de solidarité
d'urgence solide je crois que le je suis
pas d'accord avec vous quand vous dites
il faudrait des semaines et des mois
pour commercialiser parce que moi je
veux m'aimer commerce dans ma
circonscription est très réactif
utiliser les outils qu'ils avaient à
disposition
je note et vous avez raison je note que
la région ile de france a mis en place
une aide à la digitalisation mais l'état
l'a aussi fait à travers la numérisation
mais faisons c'est ce que vous disent
merci le bec qu' il faut je n'ai pas
encore dans l'incapacité et la
réactivité de nos entreprises des
citoyens et être persuadé que si il ça
méritait un débat dans la société quand
même de savoir si on veut vivre dans une
société tout se passe en ligne peut-être
qu'on peut discuter un peu démocratique
monde s'adore et c'est pas la peine de
se battre pour les coeurs de ville et
les choeurs de bourg et ne pas vraiment
les soutenir dans un certain nombre de
décisions mais la numérisation mais leur
servira toujours un jeu je vais je vais
vous dire le plan de relance que nous
soutenons dont globalement tepa pierre
laurent mais la majorité c'est un salon
vous confirme bien emmener pas
déconcentrer au niveau des entreprises
sur les territoires auprès des préfets
dans la relation avec les élus je veux
bien prendre rendez-vous nous retrouver
ici on en aura pas consommer 50 concerts
bon ben alors des dancoisne ont
concentré le torse à rentrer en place un
an et demi on raisonne laurent kerleroux
il a posé une question démocratique
important
rôle et la place du parlement on n'a pas
la même il a aussi parlé mais je pense
qu'il a posé une question majeure plus
les temps sont difficiles
plus nous vivons des moments tendus au
plan des libertés pluie
on a besoin de parler à pierre laurent
marie le bec vont repartir avec ça et
avec les réponses à leurs questions et
aux débats qu'ils ont bien voulu mener
ce soir sur le plateau
merci d'avoir été avec nous on fait un
dernier détour par le figaro live où
nous attend vincent roux bonsoir vincent
qu'est-ce qu'on soit franc que vos
lecteurs marché où nos téléspectateurs
ont retenu on lui peut-être aussi
ailleurs ici ou là alors ben justement
jeu on a passé la journée sur les
portables comme gérard larcher et on a
remarqué qu' il y a quelque chose de
très commentée sur les réseaux
c'est cette petite phrase du philosophe
et sociologue edgar morin ce matin sur
europe 1 concernant les caricatures de
charlie hebdo qui déclare ce n'était pas
la liberté française s'était simplement
sur ces caricatures qui ont valu donc à
ça mais elle pâtit d'être assassinés ou
bien ces grandes manifestations et 1
française à travers le monde vous est ce
que c'est votre point de vue gérard
larcher est-ce que ça n'était pas la
culture française mais que des
caricatures
c'était des caricatures mais qui font
partie de la liberté que notre pays
assure vous savez j'avais rendez vous
avec cabu le surlendemain où il a été
assassiné
il m'avait demandé à me voir pour me
dire peut-on rire de tout je ne dis pas
que je partageais l'ensemble des
caricatures qui a été produit dans
charlie hebdo ou mais je pense que la
liberté la liberté d'expression est
quelque chose de fondamental qu'elle est
essentielle et qu'on ne transige pas
avec la liberté d'expression
est ce que vous êtes choqués par les
propos des deux gars mais je ne suis pas
choqué parce que comme voltaire j'ai
envie que chacun puisse s'exprimer
je me battrai jusqu'au bout pour qu'il
puisse exprimer des avis différents mais
je crois profondément à cette question
de la liberté va 100 ça a beaucoup fait
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux ça chez
vous du coup en tout cas si j'ai bien
compris ça fait beaucoup réagir
effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux
merci vincent
merci gérard larcher d'avoir participé
aux auditions publiques une émission
qu'on peut retrouver sur le figaro live
notamment mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur les comptes twitter de
lcp public sénat qui ont relayé les
missions pendant toute la durée de cette
émission audition publique revient en
direct lundi à 19h30 bonne soirée
merci merci d'abord me public sénat en
bout
[Musique]